first of all let's start with the masked
singer season three people have really
got invested in this show what are you
gonna do in season three that's going to
shock us have even worse dance moves
during the performances what is that
what I'm terrible at it but it's not
about me this isn't about me it's about
this show being the number one show in
America family-friendly fun and we won
update the season how the people we got
are unbelievable so Jamie Foxx is the
guest judge and the first week and we
all get the first unmasking wrong we get
it so wrong that we all almost faint
because when you see the person get
unmasked you're gonna America is going
to freak out and you're all gonna get it
wrong no one's gonna get it
it's that shocking because there are
some great shocks last oh my god the
shocks are one after all it's like
earthquake after earthquake after
earthquake I think oh no we're not going
to top that first unmasking then the
second and the third and the fourth are
all have been completely mind-blowing
did you have a favor from last season oh
that's really tough I mean I gotta go
with Wayne Brady I didn't guess Wayne
Brady I don't know why but he is
unbelievable performer clearly you
didn't get his first album he's gonna
eat pee coming out I'll be getting that
one Wayne yes all right the other judges
you guys seem to have such great
chemistry what is it about the chemistry
that makes it work you know what being
in a show that's not judging right it
makes all the difference in the world
because we're not really competing with
each other we don't have to be you know
insulting to the contestants we're not
saying you know you need to come back
next week and bring it it's all about
family friendly fun and the game of
who's under the mask
right so it's much easier to enjoy each
other and have fun with it has there
been a time where you've been walking
around and you've secretly seen someone
you're like oh my god I know where that
is they would never let anyone see
accidentally who it was they put on
helmets not only the celebrity but the
celebrities managers and agents and so
you never see them and then it's so
confidential the audience has to sign
confidentiality so it's like Game of
Thrones finale confidential how are you
guys gonna blow us away you're coming
off the Super Bowl the biggest audience
in the world and then it comes right to
your show what can we expect for that
first episode I don't know maybe a
couple of Super Bowl people maybe I
could be lying but maybe I'm not but it
doesn't matter because the the unmasking
of the premiere is mind-blowing it's
that good
yes it's shocking because we all get it
wrong we're just the clues that
everything the singing you tricked us
and boom when you see who it is so
really really focus on the clues well
maybe that too they made it much more
difficult this year they made the clues
difficult they're more abstract and
vague so you really have to put on your
detective hat to figure it out
[Music]